it's been over a week since thousands of
people were killed when two dams burst
and sent a wall of water and mud
crashing through the eastern city of
delna
the search for bodies goes on
thousands of people are missing and fear
dead
many bodies are so decomposed that
identifying them is proving difficult
and disturbing for search and rescue
teams
as a Libyan when I pull out bodies I
swear I cry I can't handle it but it is
God's will so you have to hold up and
pull out the body
there was a body that was cut into two
parts right before us there is nothing
to do but to pull out the bodies what
can you do
with so many people unaccounted for and
so many presumed dead the threat of
disease increases by the day
some survivors have returned to what
remains of their homes and are overcome
with grief
we found dead bodies of neighbors
friends and loved ones I cannot explain
it
Libya has been a deeply divided country
for years
donation centers like this one in
Tripoli have been set up across the
country volunteers are crossing front
lines ignoring violence and political
unrest that have existed for years in
order to help those in need in the east
many survivors want to know how this
disaster happened and who might be
responsible
family of six from my extended family
there are more than 48 people missing
God will punish the people who were
supposed to take care of the dam
the UN says that more than 40 000 people
have been forced to flee their homes
it was like a dream that we can't
comprehend we just can't comprehend it
yet
help from abroad continues to arrive but
so far International and Libyan
officials say it's just not enough Malik
trainer Al Jazeera Tripoli
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera